[Music]
welcome everybody to the inaugural nil
summit and nil awards
in july 2022 atlanta hosted what might
sound like a boring legal seminar a
conference on the new rules around name
image and likeness in sports
[Music]
but far from dry and academic the first
annual nil summit was in fact a flashy
star-studded event put on at the college
football hall of fame
and mingling amid the biggest current
and former names in sports and media
there was a crucial cohort the player is
poised to redefine what it means to be a
modern college athlete
and the winner of male athlete of the
year
goes to
chase griffin
among those up-and-comers ucla's chase
griffin
the ucla quarterback is among the
students becoming as well known for
making deals as making plays
and even in that group chase stands out
my name is chase griffin what's up
everyone it's chase griffin it's your
favorite quarterback's favorite
quarterback chase griffin when you look
at it as an empowerment equity
opportunity it's really been unmatched
in the sports world for any point in
time since title 9.
after hardly a full year of name image
and likeness deals being a reality he
already has more than 20 deals with
major brands venture and charitable
groups all the while balancing
graduating undergrad in just two years
and fighting for playing time on the
field chase griffin out of the gun we
are joined by ucla quarterback chase
griffin not just ucla quarterback but
name image like this superstar i am
psyched for this one this kid could
actually be the president of the united
states someday
chase isn't the starting quarterback for
ucla he's not even the backup
quarterback but back on campus in la his
nickname is president chase
and after spending a couple days talking
about his approach to business sports
inequality it's not shocking to think he
might someday hold that office his level
of focus and maturity at this stage i
only wish i had if you want to buy stock
in a human being buy stock and chase
griffin when it comes to building
generational wealth it's not about the
money that you make in college i'm very
excited that i made the amount of money
that i made last year i am even 10 times
more excited that i know how to make
that money
[Music]
somewhere on any college campuses mostly
for the athletes who are on lighter but
still regimented schedules
attending classes working out a little
bit of hanging out and then more working
out on their own time
chase is no exception
[Music]
the 21 year old is a backup albeit an
impatient one
in the topsy-turvy past couple of
seasons dotted with fanless games and
covet protocols he's been able to start
three games for the bruins griffin gonna
throw to the end zone wide open again
touchdown ucla beating arizona and
narrowly losing to both stamford and
oregon that was inches away from chase
griffin and ucla
being in full-fledged comeback mode
for chase ucla felt like destiny he was
born just a few miles away before his
family moved to texas when he was a
toddler
but beyond being a sort of homecoming
the school's history of athlete activism
was a massive draw
i always expected from myself to
have some sort of impact that was
beneficial for more people than
i interact with on a daily basis
and in choosing ucla
a lot of that went into
me seeing myself as someone who
reflected the same
want to make things better
that so many of the people that ucla
prides itself upon being the home for
have done in the past
the legacies of former ucla greats like
arthur ashe jackie robinson kareem
abdul-jabbar and jackie joyner kersey
have had a wide-ranging impact on
society well beyond the westwood campus
chase reveres these people but he's
perhaps most keenly aware of the
activism of a more recent bruin alum the
basketball player ed o'bannon
ed o'bannon who was naismith player of
the year national champ ucla sports
legend is also a legal hero
i think nio could be the next
installment where we look back in 30 40
50 years
and god willing if we
give him the roses he deserves we add
that o man into that list of ucla grades
o'bannon who played at ucla from 91 to
95 initiated a lawsuit that's widely
credited for finally opening up the
possibility of college athletes being
paid for use of their name image and
likeness he sued the ncaa and video game
publisher ea for anti-trust violations
arguing that athletes should be entitled
to financial compensation when schools
use their likeness for gain
in 2014 a judge ruled in his favor
[Music]
and then on an episode of the shop
surrounded by o'bannon diana taurasi and
lebron james california governor gavin
newsom signed the first ultimately
successful legislation to allow athletes
to receive endorsement deals
the fair pay-to-play act led other
states to follow suit and ultimately led
the ncaa in 2021 to relent
seemingly reluctantly nil payments were
officially allowed as of july 1 2021
today is the last day where name image
and likeness laws will not be on the
books and kids will not be if you will
not allowed to make money off of their
name image and like list making money
from jersey sales and endorsement deals
is a way for players to share in the
massively lucrative world of college
athletics this nil thing is the wild
wild west the nil change felt like many
things that happened very slowly and
then it happened very fast and i wonder
for you
having contemplated that maybe this was
coming at some point
how prepared were you what was your
mindset when the switch flipped right i
mean i still think everyone's trying to
get prepared for that industry it's
still sort of like a wild wild west i
wasn't really
expecting anything i was more just
thinking about
honestly getting ready for that season
and uh
and and capitalizing on on everything
that was happening
when nil hit and it turned out i had
action i was like oh okay well after
this degree deal which was fantastic i
was like okay i see how i can be a
staple in this game and i see how i can
get better over time that's why i teamed
up with my friends at shell now
then you keep on building clear cover
like you keep on building and you get
better in the meetings
and most of all you start seeing where
your value can be best placed in these
new opportunities
the headlines and storylines in the
aftermath of the nil change introduce
visions of instant millionaires
strolling campuses across the nation
you might think the nil athlete of the
year lives in splendor or at least in
one of those athletic palaces that put
most of our college dorms to shame well
it's all relative to chase
all right jason so here we are world
headquarters yup this is where it all
happens so this is the kitchen right
here i actually really enjoy cooking oh
yeah yeah this gas oven gets really hot
really fast so i make pizzas in there
this is the best appliance
since the iphone air fryer you can put
anything in there i need to do these
dishes right here
so no trappings of success yet more a
pretty average college dorm room
the fridge filled with leftovers a
well-used ps4 and of course the
requisite godfather poster
it's a far cry from the lifestyles seen
in some local news reports for nil
athletes during this first year dijon
robinson made headlines with an nil deal
with lamborghini austin
lamborghinis tend to make more headlines
than muhammad ali or bruce lee pictures
some athletes are living in mansions
driving lamborghinis as far as i know
you're doing neither of those things i
see where you're living right here it is
it is uh with all due respect not a
mansion okay um
how much of that is a conscious choice
and and what does it say about sort of
your approach to this right i mean
first off i look at this is like it's my
own room i got everything i need i'm
cool with that i'm cool with living
below my means i think it's important to
remember that
the
volume of financial gain is completely
overstated and that's what are y'all's
fault in the media you know when someone
hears about a 5 million or 10 million
dollar deal you got to report it like oh
my goodness people are going to read
this hey
i'd count two things like how many kids
are even getting these deals and then
for the kids that do get it how much of
that is in liquor cash and how much of
it is in assets if you pay for a 2
million dollar house out here in l.a for
a kid to stay in college that's great
but
as soon as they're graduated they're not
going to have that 2 million house i say
the same thing you know for the kids who
who are driving around in lamborghinis
and stuff like that that's awesome like
that's super dope and i know some of
those kids but you know someone paying
for your lease is different than someone
actually giving you the value of that
lease every single month you're
investing in saving it 401k etc um i say
all that just uh to mention that product
deals and stuff like that are over hyped
um by the media and they also can land
kids in some trouble if they're not
paying taxes on it
[Music]
that's one of the distinctly unsexy and
easy to overlook elements of the new
rules
even if an athlete's not getting cold
hard cash from a deal the value of any
products given are subject to state and
federal taxes
so suddenly what a player sees as free
gear in return for some social media
posts
actually equals taxable income
and that requires the same forms you'd
fill out as an independent contractor
getting a check i made a fair amount in
nio deals and i invested all of it in my
opinion nio is great doing all this is
great making money now is great but the
most valuable thing i've gotten from all
of this is the fact i'll always know how
to make money off of myself
all told chase has done more than 20
deals with major brands like degree
shell and boost mobile along with
venture stage companies including
discord duffel and creative juice he's
also made a point to work with charities
like the los angeles regional food bank
where he's already raised funds for
almost 60 000 meals
there's a song about it julian i heard
the opening i liked it
i just took that opening and i pitched
it slow i think i sped it
[Music]
at his desk when he's not making music
another side project he's either
networking with ceos or investors he
seeks out or who seek him out
or negotiating new deals
hey mallory
hi chase how are you doing i'm doing
well i'm turning on my camera right now
yeah no worries
this is an average nil deal a brand
approaches an athlete who can help
spread their message to a demographic
they believe the athlete can help reach
in this case directv is looking to
market their nfl sunday ticket to
college students it would be two posts
one post late august and one post um the
first week of september and the
compensation would be 1200 per post so
it would be 400 total right perfect are
are they video posts or are they uh you
know pick and caption they can be either
it's up to you guys
that was pretty good uh
400 above what they had originally asked
so that's a win
so yeah i mean at this point after
i do
a zoom or something like that i either
chill out go back to laying down if i
was watching a movie or something
or you know
go to youtube to start looking for more
samples
this is presidential change
it's a pretty simple interaction for
chase and for directv
negotiated over a couple of emails and
zoom calls and papered with a contract
chase will have his dad look over before
he signs
and chase who's made himself as much of
a student of the new nil marketplace as
he has a public policy at ucla
says he understands why it's working
a brand ambassador with ship with an
athlete is
more attractive to these brands now as
far as return on investment than even
a post by a famous actor
if there's any place to learn that
sports are deep in the hearts of
americans it's on a high school football
field in texas
[Music]
friday night lights in the lone star
state might be the gridiron equivalent
of frank sinatra's new york city
making it there means you're something
special chase griffin quarterback class
of 19 huddle texas
and chase didn't just make it he
excelled
let's talk about some of the top
quarterbacks in the state and when you
look at that list at the top of it you
got to talk about chase griffin i was
lucky to play three years as a
quarterback for huddle high school which
is a one horse town we have great
success and so the town really shut down
and came out and supported us every
friday night chase
touchdown
chase one word to describe that finish
to that game god that's it
coming from a town like that where
football was so prioritized it has its
pros and cons but i think on the pro
side i learned how to win how to get
better and most importantly what it's
like to build a team where everyone gets
better
[Music]
emulating his ucla alumni like robinson
joiner kersey and abdul jabbar chase is
looking at the impact nil will have not
just for him but the athletes that will
follow
when the predecessors who have come
before you have changed the world and
made life better for everyone today you
can't help but ask yourself how the
actions that you're taking now and the
companies and brands in the nioh space
that you work with are all
cumulatively building
something greater than any of us could
foresee
[Music]
i've actually i've never moderated so
this will be my first time should be fun
i know my handwriting is terrible
the last day of the conference chase was
asked to co-moderate a panel with
monique nelson the ceo for uniworld
group all right i'm excited to be here
uniworld group is one of the longest
standing multicultural advertising and
marketing agencies in the united states
the firm works with brands like ford
home depot and johnson johnson to help
reach the black and brown communities
and they have big ambitions in nil
for uniworld group the the idea of this
was
pretty epic in that because we serve
the undervalued overlooked
and the underserved
we knew that this particular group of
people would fall into that category
and we plan on being the premier
practice for nil
athletes that are looking to do
purpose-driven
media advertising
community level engagement work
uwg launched a program called the nile
to help black student athletes partner
with major brands but to help them
understand how to do that they brought
on chase to serve as a student athlete
executive in residence
for me i do nothing without tremendous
amounts of data for all of our clients i
really wanted to be thoughtful about
this practice being very athlete centric
if i were to build it or anyone on my
team were to build it it would not have
the athlete at the core
when you know you're 18 19 20 21 and 22
the best way
to have credibility is confidence
and the only way for confidence to be
authentic
i'm actually learning on the job i'm
learning about the brand side of nio but
i'm also trying to make sure that
empowerment equity is built in
especially for black student athletes in
the nio world
roi return on investment
athletes both chase and uwg see nil
deals as something much more than making
money for students
[Music]
it's also a potential investment in a
community long overlooked i think we're
getting ready to stock boxes
to kind of feed the people of l.a
a piece of each of chase's nil deals go
to his believe brand campaign which has
raised more than thirteen thousand
dollars for meals for the la food bank
backpack program
but athletes giving back is only one
side
i'm here with legalzoom to give you five
tips on the nio game plan
uwg and chase believe having brands
investing in the athletes especially
athletes of color can be a force
multiplier for these historically
marginalized communities
when you look at the revenue jet and
rating sports football and basketball 88
of those athletes are black so when
you're doing stuff to empower student
athletes in the aisle space you're also
helping to deliver on your promise now
student athletes are not the only ones
who should receive this hope by any
means but statistically by doing that
you're going to be delivering on your
mission additionally student athletes on
average come from
lower levels of income so you're also
delivering on that promise
and a lot of these student-athletes are
first-generation they're first-gen
college students some of them first-gen
high school diploma some of them first
time receiving the amount of money that
they
received
in their families
this has been a wild first year in nil
we all knew that there would be bags of
cash around right there's always been
bags of cash there's cash everywhere
what we know is that that's not
sustainable we know that athletics has
an expiration date on it
so for us inclusion ultimately means
this is just a part of you it is a
tremendous part of you and we are going
to celebrate that part of you but we
also know that you're bigger than that
so we want to empower you to live past
your expiration date for this part of
your life
and quite honestly have equity in
everything that you have poured yourself
into as an nil athlete
it may still be the wild west days for
the nil industry but in the first year
about a billion dollars in business was
done with ncaa athletes
for the early leaders in the nil space
like chase they're striking a precedent
for athletes that follow them and that's
important because collegiate athletes
don't have that much time to profit
only an estimated 2 percent of ncaa
athletes go on to the pros
even the hardest working are often
limited by things they can't control
for chase it's been his height
[Music]
i'm 5 10 now in high school after my
sophomore year when i threw for 3000
yards i was probably like five six five
five
i mean i could arguably say i'm one of
the best in the history of texas high
school football but you know i've gone
through the height test where they'll
call you out of class shake your hand
look at you up and down and be like nice
to meet you you go back to class
it's a sad but timeless story for
student athletes and for chase his story
is something he's not shy away from but
embraced when it comes to his nil deals
i'm frequently the smallest person on
the football field but i always strive
to be the most impactful
my middle school coach
told me that i would never play in high
school
chase's deals with degrees breaking
limits team and clear covers inspired
underdogs allowed him to capitalize
financially from football even though
last season he never saw the field for
ucla i play football because i love the
game i play the football because i'm a
good competitor i love to compete and i
play football because i'm good at it
at the end of the day i don't play
football for my livelihood which is
important to remember when it comes down
to identity
i'm myself chase griffin as long as i'm
that
i got something in this world
as he moves into the new season and
focuses more on football than business
chase doesn't see much of a
differentiation between the two in terms
of his mindset i wouldn't be surprised
if i wasn't playing football in five
years and was running a fortune 500
company but i also wouldn't be surprised
if i was winning the super bowl five ten
years from now and either way
i'm going to keep on working at the
tools that would align myself and my
future with both and at the end of the
day
you're always going to have yourself if
you can make profit off of yourself and
know where you add value in any world
you're in you'll be able to adapt and
find ways to generate wealth for
yourself
[Music]
you